[تصفيق]
صيحات وطلقات مدافع قطع عسكريه عملاقه
وتشكيلات من مختلف الوحدات المقاتله
تستعرض قوتها وتتباهى بالنصر على العدو
مشاعر الفخر تسود هنا بين الجموع وسط
الساحه الحمراء في موسكو انه التاسع من
مايو ذكرى يوم النصر الروسي العظيم
[موسيقى]
عام
1941 قرر هتلر غزو روسيا توغل النازي على
حدود الاتحاد السوفيتي اذا نجح سينهار
التكتل المرعب وقد يقع ستالين في قبضه
الالمان لكن رياح الحرب لم تاتي كما يشتهي
هتلر فقوات ستالين ادرى بشعاب بلادها
وبردها القارص الذي كان سببا رئيسيا في شل
حركه الجيش الالماني وقتنا نجح السوفيتي
في صد هجمات القوات النازيه وبدا السقوط
يتوالى في صفوف الالمان الساعه الان تشير
الى 11 قبل منتصف الليل من يوم الثامن من
مايو عام 45 الاخبار المتداوله وقتها تؤكد
ان الالمان هزمت وبالفعل يعلن الالمان وقف
جميع العمليات العسكريه ويقرون بهزيمتهم
رسميا في الحرب العالميه الثانيه بل
ويوقعون استسلاما غير مشروط ليعلن للعالم
انتصار روسيا على النازيه ومنذ تلك اللحظه
اتخذت موسكو تاريخ التاسع من مايو من كل
عام عيد نصر لشعبها وقواتها المسلحه
نشات
تاريخيا لم تكن ليوم النصر في روسيا اهميه
وطنيه عند غالبيه الشعر حتى جاء زعيم
السوفيتي في عام
1963 واقل سياسه تقديس النصر في الحرب ضد
المانيا النازيه لتقويه وتعزيز المشاعر
الوطنيه في هذا اليوم بالتحديد واحياء
ذكرى نحو 20 مليون مواطن سوفيتي قضوا في
الحرب العالميه الثانيه وهو ما اكمله
الرئيس الحالي
الذي يريد ان يكون يوم النصر جزءا لا
يتجزا من الهويه الروسيه
وتذكيرا للنازيين الجدد على حد وصفه بان
المواجهه امر لا مفر منه
الغرب هو من اطلق الحرب ضد روسيا عبر
استعمال اوكرانيا هم من اطلقوا المارد من
القمقم العمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا جاءت
لضمان امن البلاد وللقضاء على التهديد
الذي يشكله نظام نازيين الجدد في اوكرانيا
عن احتفالات بيوم النصر تبدا في الساعه
التاسعه وخمسين دقيقه صباحا بتوقيت موسكو
بالتزامن مع وصول الرئيس والرئيس الوزراء
الروسيين الى مدرج رئيسي امام دار حيلينا
وفي تمام العاشره صباحا تدق اجراس برج
سباس كايا في الكرمله
[موسيقى]
حينها يامر قائد العرض القوات الموجوده
بتقديم التحيه العسكريه لحمله الاعلام من
فرقه حرس الشرف الاولى الذين يسيرون
حاملين كلا من عالم روسيا ورايه النصر
السوفيتيه الحمراء مع عزف موسيقى مارش
الحرب المقدسه
[موسيقى]
يشارك عاده اكثر من عشرين الف مجند ومئه
طائرات والمدرعات في عرض عسكري مهيب يتم
فيه استعراض احدث المعدات العسكريه
الروسيه في رساله مفادها ان روسيا قوه لا
يستهان بها وان من استطاع هزيمه المانيا
النازيه في الحرب العالميه الثانيه لن
يعجز عن تحقيق نصر جديد